The main aim of any given movie is to encapsulate
its audience.
As a general rule, that's the job of the actors,
so the audience's eyes are generally focused
on them.
Whether it's through breathtaking action,
hilarity, sheer emotionally-inspiring brilliance
or otherwise, an actor's performance is designed
to keep an audience fixated.Sometimes that
can mean missing interesting, weird and wonderful
things that might be going on in the background;
Extras behaving strangely, bizarre cameos,
strange objects or things that simply shouldn't
be there have all been seen in the background
of movies.
This video will take a look at some great
examples of those things.
Here are the ten weirdest things found in
the background of famous movies scenes.
Ron Jeremy in Ghostbusters
Set in New York City, 1984's Ghostbusters
saw the titular team - played by Bill Murray,
Dan Aykroyd, Harold Ramis and Ernie Hudson
respectively - defending the Big Apple from
a wave of supernatural beings and activity.
Towards the end of the movie, after their
ghost containment unit had exploded, a crowd
of people gathered to witness the resulting
devastation.
That crowd was mostly made up of generic acting
extras, but if you look close enough, you'll
actually see that a legend of the pornographic
industry was among them.
None other than Ron Jeremy himself - sporting
his iconic trademark moustache - can be seen
to the left of the screen in one particular
shot.
A Man Throwing a Dog in the Ocean in Mr. Nanny
Hulk Hogan in movies... that's something we'd
all rather forget, right?
Well, sadly, it definitely happened, as the
early 1990s saw the wrestling superstar failing
emphatically in his attempts to become the
next Arnold Schwarzenegger.
1993's Mr. Nanny was atrocious, but the weirdest
thing in the movie happened very randomly
in the background.
As Hogan's character was riding on his motorcyle
near the ocean, a random guy can be briefly
seen throwing his dog into the water behind
him.
It's a good job Hogan didn't notice this bizarre
act by the man in question, as it might have
resulted in Hulkamania running wild all over
him, brothers!
The Gross Restaurant Name in Anchorman
In the hilarious Anchorman: The Legend of
Ron Burgundy, Christina Applegate's Veronica
Corningstone - Burgundy's rival, lover and
eventual co-anchor - visits a Mexican restaurant
with a group of her female co-workers.
Prior to the scene in question, the sign for
the restaurant is shown on screen.
Its name is “Escupimos en su Alimento”,
which means absolutely nothing to the movie's
predominantly English-speaking audience.
However, when the name is translated into
English, it actually means “We spit in your
food.”
Nice, huh?
Tyler Durden's Facebook Page in The Social
Network
In David Fincher's brilliant The Social Network,
Mark Zuckerberg was played by Jesse Eisenberg.
In one particular scene in the movie, Eisenberg's
Zuckerberg is seeing working on Facebook at
his computer.
For a brief moment, he could be seen on the
profile of a certain Tyler Durden, as the
words "Tyler Durden's Photos" were clearly
visible on screen.
Tyler Durden was, of course, the iconic main
character in Fight Club - a movie that was
also helmed by Fincher earlier in his career.
The Kid Needing to Pee in Back to the Future
Part III
At the end of Back to the Future Part III,
when Christopher Lloyd's Emmett Brown returns
from his time-travelling exploits to visit
Marty McFly in the present day, he reveals
that he and Clara had produced two children
- Jules and Verne.
While Emmett and Marty are chatting, in the
background, the child playing Verne can be
seen making a "come on" gesture whilst pointing
at his crotch.
One theory regarding this is that he was indicating
that he needed to use the bathroom, while
another suggests he was mimicking a gesture
being made off-camera by a member of the movie's
crew.
Either way, it's a little bit creepy.
An Extra Falls to the Floor For No Reason
in The Dark Knight Rises
As a general rule, the fight choreography
in all three of Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
Trilogy movies was pretty amazing, but a particular
scene in The Dark Knight Rises had a very
farcical moment in it.
There's a scene on a rooftop in which Christian
Bale's Batman and Anne Hathaway's Catwoman
are fighting Bane's henchman and, in the background,
you can see one the extras portraying one
of the henchman in a combat pose.
Then, out of nowhere, without anyone actually
touching him, he falls to the ground as if
he'd been nailed by the Dark Knight.
Nice work, Mr. Extra
A Man in a Cowboy Hat in Pirates of the Caribbean:
The Curse of the Black Pearl
In the final scene of Pirates of the Caribbean:
The Curse of the Black Pearl, after reclaiming
the Black Pearl itself, Johnny Depp's Captain
Jack Sparrow orders his merry band of pirates
to get to work on the deck.
As they start to spread out in order to get
on with their respective duties, a very out-of-place
man can be seen in the background wearing
a white T-shirt and a cowboy hat, staring
out into the ocean.
Basically, a crew member had managed to accidentally
place himself in shot and nobody noticed it
during the post-production process.
Shiver me timbers!
Pac-Man in Tron
The very nature of Tron meant that it was
begging to be packed with video game references
and Easter eggs - and there were indeed several.
The most prominent allusion to any video game,
however, is definitely Pac-Man.
When one of the movie's antagonists, Sark,
is on the bridge of his command ship surveying
a map of the system, a tiny Pac-Man can be
seen working his way around the map.
Moreover, if you listen carefully enough,
you can even hear the sound effects from the
game - namely the noise Pac-Man himself makes
as he makes his way around his maze-like levels.
R2-D2 in Star Trek Into Darkness
Star Trek and Star Wars have long been seen
as the two mightiest science-fiction franchises
in Hollywood and, as a result, there's something
of a rivalry between the two franchises and
their fans.
However, in Star Trek Into Darkness, there's
actually something of a minor crossover between
the two.
In the middle of the Vengeance's attack on
the U.S.S.
Enterprise in the movie, when part of the
iconic starship was badly damaged, Star Wars
character R2-D2 can be seen being sucked out
of it and propelled into space.
Of course, J.J. Abrams was on directorial
duties for this movie - and he would later
go on to direct Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
Given that he's a fan of both franchises,
that probably explains this.
Captain America's Shield in Iron Man
Thinking about it now, seeing Captain America's
shield in any Marvel Cinematic Universe movie
wouldn't be much of a surprise.
However, when a prototype of it first appeared
on Tony Stark’s work bench in the first
Iron Man movie back in 2008, it was nothing
short of mind-blowing for comic book fans.
At that time, shared comic book movie universes
didn't even exist and a Captain America movie
wasn’t even on the cards, so it was really
quite a surprise to see it.
Of course, since then, the prototype appeared
even more prominently in Iron Man 2 and Captain
America has had three of his own movies, as
well as appearing in two Avengers ensemble
offerings, but that doesn't alter the fact
that it was strange seeing it at the the time.
Thanks for watching our list of the ten weirdest
things found in the background of famous movies
scenes.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other strange things have you seen in
the background of famous movies?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.